welcome to cloud security basics a new
series where we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application on Google
cloud sound fun then stick around
because in this episode you'll learn
about Google clouds physical defence of
their data centers and hardware
[Music]
hello cloud detective you may have
solved last week's question about
securing customers data but what about
securing the data center is another
physical hardware that runs your
software even if everything else in your
ecosystem is secure what will you do
about machine or supply chain related
issues how can you be sure the physical
devices are being properly secured or
what if some bad actor plants malware on
your precious machines what can you do
to stop that for your sake I hope you
know the answer to my question okay
here's what we know physical security
has two components securing the physical
servers and the data centers that data
lives on and ensuring the physical and
virtual systems that applications rely
on are secure like with a route of trust
if the physical devices aren't being
properly secured someone could steal a
machine with your data on it
plant malware on it or otherwise tapper
with the machines compromising the
security of anyone who uses those
instances luckily Google cloud provides
a lot of tools and services to protect
its users when it comes to securing the
physical premises and hardware access to
Google data centers is limited to a
small number of specially qualified
Google employees less than 1% of
Googlers will ever set foot into a data
center access to the data center floor
is only possible via a security corridor
which implements multi-factor access
controls using security badges and
biometrics when it comes to securing the
virtualization and hardware components
software runs on Google has designed a
lot of custom tooling to protect its
users Google data centers have thousands
of server machines connected to a local
network providing an initial layer of
security both the server boards and the
networking equipment are custom-designed
by Google to adhere to their tough
security requirements and Google's
custom design tighten hardware security
chip can be deployed on both servers and
peripherals allowing Google to identify
and authenticate devices at the hardware
level with security like that you can be
sure the hardware your software runs on
is secure let's see a few specific
examples of how Google secures the
platform
so how does Google cloud secure the data
centers and other physical hardware that
runs your software hmm first let's talk
about securing the data center on top of
technologies like biometric
identification metal detectors camera
physical barriers and laser based
intrusion detection as you get closer to
the data center floor security measures
also increase access to the data center
floor is only possible via security
corridor which implements multi-factor
access controls using security badges
and biometrics plus data centers are
routinely patrolled by experienced
security guards who've undergone
rigorous background checks and training
so that's the physical defence of data
centers but what about virtual and real
Hardware security well there's a Titan
ship Titan is a secure low-power
microcontroller designed with Google's
security requirements and hardware
scenarios in mind Titan provides a
hardware based route of trust that
establishes a strong identity for a
machine which enables Google to make
important security decisions and
validate the health of the system Titan
offers integrity verification of
firmware and software components the
system's strong identity ensures that
there's a true audit trail of any
changes done to the system
tamper-evident login capabilities help
identify actions perform by an insider
with root access all of these features
come together to allow Google to
securely run operating systems that have
been verified and authenticated and then
there's KVM or the kernel-based virtual
machine that Google uses as the
foundations of Google compute engine and
Google kubernetes engine KVM is an open
source virtualization technology built
right into Linux it lets you turn Linux
into a hypervisor that allows one host
machine to run multiple isolated VMs
Plus Google invests in additional
security hardening and protections based
on its research and testing experiences
for example the Google security team
performs thorough code reviews each time
they adopt a new feature or version of
KVM and uses an extensive set of
proprietary fuzzing tools for KVM to
further test it Google removes unused
KVM components like legacy Mouse drivers
to reduce the attack
service for potential adversaries to
exploit and instead of using the more
complex QEMU emulator built-in to KVM
google wrote its own user space virtual
machine monitor and hardware emulator
which is simpler better tested and offer
significant security advantages these
are just a few of the steps Google's
taken a heart and KVM for its services
and its customers so we see how Google
uses hardware virtualization and
physical security to protect its tooling
hmm and I see how to answer Brad actors
question I see you've been busy
detective somehow you answered my little
question how do you secure the platform
the data center is another physical
hardware that runs your software as you
found the crux of the argument Google's
commitment to security first design
keeps the platform secure Google cloud
manages security throughout the data
lifecycle from the data center to the
device using a range of technologies and
approaches very good very good you seem
to have the basics covered but be wary
I'll return with questions about
forensic and preventative actions you've
been warned detective so there you have
it
that's another episode of cloud security
basics if you want to take a deeper dive
on how Google secures its data centers
and physical Hardware check out the
article linked in the description below
next we're going to start looking at
some preventative and forensic actions
stay tuned because when it comes to
cloud security you can't let bad actors
win
[Music]